do you feel like you're at a point right
now where you're feeling pretty
confident about where you're at
financially yeah me and my family are in
a great spot and uh
but i still i have things to do i still
have things to do i'm not there yet i
have one more box to check on my career
the ribbon on top of my mixed martial
arts career is be the undisputed world
champion that's what i want that's what
i
from the moment i walked into a gym
the first time in my life and i started
lacing up these boxing gloves i thought
of money was never on my mind it was
always to be the best and i'm still
climbing that mountain you know
you got a guy like tom brady that's how
old is he right now 68 i don't know how
old he is i think he saw
he's like 44 is he 43 or 44 with 44 and
he's still you know going out there
kicking some ass and it doesn't look
like this guy's going to stop do you
have a number like do you say i think
i'm going to go till this age or is it
you know the the diplomatic answer what
we're going to see we're going to take
it one day at a time we're going to talk
to the family and see that that's kind
of the way i've been through my whole
career but i always thought i wouldn't
fight past 35
but at 35's almost you know i'm 32. i
was saying that when i was 19 20 years
old
then you turn 32 and you're like well i
still feel pretty good 35's not that old
you know but we'll see i i want to be
the world champion that that's the goal
and as long as i can compete with these
guys wake up feeling good of course i
have aches and pains i've been fighting
a long time but as long as i can compete
with these guys i don't see why why not
why wouldn't
who do you see right now that's coming
up younger guys that's coming up where
you say that guy that guy's got a future
he could be a killer but the young guy's
coming up like the 21 year old version
of you is there any guys you're seeing
where you're
there are so many guys like that um i
trained an american top team in coconut
creek when i'm getting ready for my
fight it's not far from here
and there's just so many guys but but
also when i was 21 in the gyms the sport
wasn't nearly as big as it is now so the
amenities these gyms have the coaching
staff that these guys have we didn't
have that back then so i'm just seeing
the level of fighting getting so much
better you know
it
the guys are starting at 16 15 years old
younger than that doing jiu jitsu boxing
doing mixed martial arts back then we
had to there wasn't a mixed martial arts
gym we had to go to a boxing gym find a
jiu jitsu gym travel across town and try
to put all the stuff together ourselves
mixed martial arts is becoming its own
martial art now you have to be able to
do everything and these kids are doing
that from an early age so i'm just
seeing the level
grow so fast with these young guys man
that they're incredible you you think
ufc is going to pass up boxing
eventually where it's going to be just
more exciting to watch ufc unboxings
going to become a thing of the past or
you think boxing's always going to be
able to hang
i mean boxing's been around forever i
think ufc's gaining a lot of traction
with combat sports fans in the in the
past few years
it might be that it might be at that
point right now you know but those big
fights
the heavyweight championships of the
world
you know anthony joshua tyson fury dante
wilder those kind of fights are always
going to be
prestigious you're always going to want
to see those fights but the overall week
to week month-to-month fighting i think
ufc or mixed martial arts in general is
doing bigger things than boxing is yeah
i think i think many people would agree
with you how much of that you think is
dana where he had the startup mentality
of a barbarian seal you know coming up
and building that thing up how much of
it you think it's more you know the
fighters coming up like what kind of
credit you give for dana what he's done
they did an incredible job of building
the company up to what it is now
cashing out on it
you know within a half billion that was
a nice payoff i think they bought it for
2 million so yeah they bought it for 24
billion
good for them though yeah that's the
best part the guy who you know the guy
that started it i don't know if you know
this or not maybe it's your world
his original plan was to create a cage
fight with sharks swimming around did
you know that story with i mean can you
imagine you go too far there's shark
swimming right it's kind of a little
weird but
you got a dana comes in with two of his
investors they buy it out and the rest
is history yeah i think a little bit of
it for sure is dana his marketing
ability his his
thoughts that he he he made this to what
it is but
the fight sells itself because it's so
exciting that like i was talking about
variables there's so many ways to win
and lose in mixed martial arts
that that
it's hard to to get a boring fight
did you did you follow basketball
growing up are you a guy that followed
baseball basketball football or football
football you did okay so who was the
commissioner when you were following
football before roger goodell who
are you did you follow a lot of the
commissioner stuff or no i didn't follow
the conditions so a dana white what's
his relationship with the fighters you
know and here's what i mean by that is
it is he the boss boss like hey this
guy's the boss we got to make sure we're
going based on what he's saying does he
build relationship is he his friendship
guy does he tell you the truth behind
closers he didn't show up today i don't
know what that was all about if you
fight like this you ain't gonna get the
big fight what's his relationship with
fighters he's honest like that okay if
you go out there
leave it all out there don't play it
safe he'll bring you back
he's a pretty you know cut dry honest
guy when it comes to that type of stuff
i haven't spent a whole lot of time in
um you know with him
i've gone to vegas a few times and cut
some deals where he had to sit down with
the lawyers and stuff like that uh other
other times it's just been at events
behind the scenes you know quick chats
but he's honest uh in person
dana's yeah you almost see like the way
he uh deals with the fighters he seems
forgiving but he also seems like he's
got a pretty high standards on the way
he sets it up as long as you go out
there and fight as hard as you can
you're in a good spot with dana you're
gonna get stuff with dana because he
gets the eyeballs so crazy question for
you just crazy question this is just for
my own interest it probably has nothing
to do with the guys here
if if dana if let's just say comes to a
time where dana wants to retire walk
away who does dana's job so if you like
this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]